pareo
really good thanks for being here good
to be home now you know just thinking
about this we just did a little sketch
in the audience that ended with some
fisticuffs that was shockingly
unrealistic and it got me thinking about
your movie pride and glory you have a
fight scene with Colin Farrell that and
it this is a this is so many movies so
many fight scenes that you get jaded
there's a fight scene with you and Colin
Farrell that's so horrendously realistic
it looks like you're really kicking the
crap out of each other yeah you did
really I mean did anyone get hurt making
this because it looks like someone had
to get hurt no you need a you need a
good you need a good tango partner in
those kinds of things you need someone
who really understands that the angles
and and how to how to sell it without
killing each other so what do you mean
by the angles the angles meaning the
camera angles yeah yeah it's all like if
we're on your own yeah like this one
here this right here so you know if
we're going at it right each other this
this is a terrible angle for us you'll
sell the punch yeah that's things
because you can you can see that right
yeah right right okay so but maybe like
try agree there okay I'll cut this way a
little okay this way this way okay this
way I go that like like you know
[Applause]
network cuz you really hit me that I
think you would have been yeah it's the
goofy guy who comes in Irish and gets
hit in the face just so Colin didn't get
hurt you didn't get hurt on the probe
yeah okay now what about what's how
about Fight Club love that movie a lot
of people love that movie
that really felt like someone had to get
hurt in the making of that film there
was there was a we got Brad and I got
weird sort of parallel injuries on that
you know and if you know what the films
about it that was a little spooky but um
there's a lot of the movie where you and
Brad Pitt are basically just punching
each other in the face the fur the first
hit and that the first hit in the movie
is supposed to be a really kind of
awkward you know as your guy that
doesn't know how to fight yeah and and
we had kind of agreed that I would I
would just like connect with with you
know the Brad's kind of shoulder muscle
right and um and David Fincher walked up
right before we did the first one and I
just said he just goes hit him in the
ear in the ear and Brad Pitt do you know
that right yeah I said really I'm not
sure we're just getting going on this he
doesn't know me so well maybe that's not
a great idea and he goes no he said no
trust me hit him in the air so so I went
and just kind of clipped him with the
point of my thumb and then right here
and it's in the film yeah you can see
well you know what's interesting in that
scene because I know that scene he
actually looks really surprised he says
why the ear so all really good acting is
is just surprising people yeah
there's this ring and react reacting yes
okay there's this rumor out there that
has to be faked that there's that there
could be a Fight Club musical and I
heard that and I thought I don't know if
that ever happened I would go I don't
know how that would work
i Brad might do that I might not have
been do you think Brad would do it yeah
yeah
really he's um yeah he's I think he's
more of a musical theatre type
okay yes you know and he's got you know
he's got the whole chorus his whole
family yes well he yeah I'll go see it I
will go see I think we'll all go see it
you obviously be really strange like
yeah think about it I mean I don't even
know what the routines would be the
dance routines
Tommy is one thing but if I Club know
it's gonna happen now just we've talked
about it it's on the web now people
going to invest you'll be dragged into
it and I'll be in it too I'll be there
with you